supongamos que ese es el valor al cual
esta serie converge vamos a suponer que
esta serie
de hecho converge en la definición de
esta serie estamos suponiendo que cada
término es una función que depende de n
vamos a suponer que es una serie del
mismo tipo de las que usamos cuando
hicimos la prueba el integral es decir
esta función es una función continua
positiva y decreciente sobre el
intervalo que nos interesa es entonces
continua positiva y decreciente es una
función continua positiva y decreciente
déjame escribir lo mejor de la siguiente
manera continua positiva y decreciente
como esta el objetivo de este vídeo es
ver si podemos establecer un rango para
este valor lo cual es muy útil pues si
bien hemos visto algunas series que
convergen a un cierto valor hay
muchísimas otras series que si bien
convergen no podemos determinar de
manera analítica el valor preciso al
cual convergen lo vamos a tener que
estimar por computadora o quizás a mano
y es bueno contar con un rango de
valores para que sepamos qué
esa es nuestra estimación queremos
también obtener la mejor estimación
posible con el menor número de cálculos
veamos cómo podemos hacer esto la manera
de abordar esto es como bien puedes
imaginar separar esta suma en una suma
finita digamos de los primeros términos
desde que en es igual a 1 hasta k df de
n lo cual si en es pequeño y la forma de
f simple es fácil de calcular inclusive
a mano o lo que es seguro es que esto de
cualquier manera siempre se puede
calcular con una computadora ya está
tenemos que sumarle una serie finita
desde que n es igual a 1 desde que en es
igual acá más 1 hasta infinito de f de n
así es que si podemos establecer límites
sobre esta serie esto nos va a permitir
establecer límites sobre este valor pues
este valor está constituido por la suma
de la suma parcial de los primeros
términos más un término denominado
remanente que al sumarlo con la suma
parcial nos da el valor real digamos que
es lo que resta después de que tomamos
esa suma
parcial esta es una manera más simple de
denotar este término la clave aquí es
podemos establecer algún valor límite
para esto y para eso voy a referirme a
la gráfica y voy a utilizar las mismas
ideas los mismos conceptos que empleamos
para la prueba de la integral para
empezar hay dos maneras de
conceptualizar lo que representa esta
suma en relación a esta gráfica como
veremos puede representar una
sobreestimación del área bajo la curva
desde cierto valor de x hasta infinito o
también puede representar una
subestimación de una región diferente
relacionada con la curva veamos primero
el caso cuando el área se está
subestimando supongamos entonces que
este de aquí es que de hecho déjame
hacerlo con otro color voy a ponerlo en
amarillo
supongamos entonces que estés
este es uno estés acá más dos deja de
ponerlo más cerca
hamas dos camas tres y así y así
sucesivamente
así que una manera de conceptualizar
esta suma es como la suma de los
siguientes rectángulos así es que el
primer término corresponde a esta área
el área del primer rectángulo pues como
podemos ver aquí la altura de este
rectángulo es efe de camas uno es
efe acá más uno y la base del rectángulo
es uno así es que fedecámarás uno por
uno es el área del rectángulo que
corresponde precisamente al primer
término cuando en es igual acá más uno
ahora el segundo término por el mismo
razonamiento corresponde al área del
segundo rectángulo el tercer término al
área del tercer rectángulo y así
podríamos seguir con todos los términos
sucesivos y cuál es entonces la suma de
las áreas de todos estos rectángulos que
corresponde a la suma de estos términos
podemos considerarla como una estimación
como una estimación del área bajo la
curva entre x igual acá y x igual a
infinito pero va a ser una subestimación
observa que todos los rectángulos se
encuentran contenidos dentro de esta
región lo anterior quiere decir que
entonces resulta va a ser menor o igual
es una subestimación es una
subestimación de la integral desde x
igual acá hasta x igual infinito de fx
de x y con esto ya tenemos un límite
superior para ere de acá y esto es
interesante porque ahora ya podemos
establecer que si ese es es igual a la
suma parcial más se reduzca y r sub que
es menor o igual a esta integral
entonces s es menor o igual a la suma
parcial s su k más
más la integral impropia desde que x es
igual acá hasta que x es igual infinito
de fx de x observa s es igual a esto ere
sub k es menor que esta integral y
propia entonces s es menor que la suma
de estos dos términos así es que si
podemos calcular el valor de estos dos
términos que a menudo es posible hacerlo
podemos poner un límite superior para el
valor de s pero ahora como obtenemos un
límite inferior bien podemos
conceptualizar esta misma suma la misma
rdk de tal manera que el primer
rectángulo el primero de los rectángulos
cuyas áreas vamos a sumar no es este de
aquí sino es este rectángulo de acá
observa tiene la misma altura pero lo
hemos trasladado a una unidad a la
derecha este rectángulo representa el
segundo término este de aquí representa
el tercer término y así y porque esto
también es correcto el área del primer
rectángulo es la altura que es
efe de camas 1 también multiplicado por
su base que es 1 lo cual nos da efe de
camas 1 así es que esta área corresponde
al primer término el segundo término
estaría representado por esta área
este es el área el tercer término esta
es la del cuarto término y como
mencionamos una mano
considerar esto es que hemos trasladado
todos los rectángulos que teníamos en
amarillo una unidad a la derecha pero
ahora estamos aproximando el valor de
una región distinta estamos aproximando
el área bajo la curva no desde acá hasta
infinito sino desde acá más 1 hasta
infinito y en vez de ser una
subestimación es una sobreestimación
ahora el área bajo la curva está
contenida totalmente dentro de los
rectángulos así es que ahora podemos
establecer que eres uca bajo esta
perspectiva es mayor o igual a la
integral no desde acá sino desde acá más
1 hasta infinito de fx de equis y esto
que nos lleva bien aquí estamos
estableciendo un límite inferior para
esto lo cual también nos da un límite
inferior para esto sí hemos encontrado
que esto es mayor que esto entonces esto
de aquí es mayor que esto sustituyendo
la integral impropia ahora tenemos que
entonces ese es mayor o igual
s sub acá
más la integral impropia desde x igual a
uno hasta x igual infinito de fx de x y
aquí podrías decir oye sal esto es una
locura aquí tienes esta anotación
extraña además aparecen unas integrales
que deben de ser muy complicadas de
evaluar pero como veremos en próximos
vídeos en muchas ocasiones estas
integrales son simples de evaluar este
término se evalúa directamente si k no
es muy grande si llegara a ser muy
grande se hace con una computadora y
estas integrales quizás en ocasiones
haya que evaluarlas numéricamente pero
en muchas otras ocasiones es posible
evaluar las de manera analítica es decir
usando lo que podríamos denominar el
poder del cálculo y lo que estamos
haciendo aquí es establecer límites
precisos para el valor hacia el cual la
serie converge y como veremos a medida
que crece el valor de k se hace mejor el
valor de la estimación y el intervalo
que contiene la estimación se va
haciendo cada vez más pequeño otra
manera de escribir estas dos
desigualdades es con una desigualdad
compuesta podemos escribir que s es
menor o igual que esto de aquí
déjame copiar
copiar esto y pegar es menor o igual que
esto y también y también que ese es
mayor o igual que esto o esto es menor o
igual que ese s es mayor o igual que
esto de aquí voy a copiar
pegar no eso es lo que quería ser déjame
copiar y pegar ahora si en los
siguientes vídeos
vamos a aplicar esto que hemos
establecido aquí veremos que en realidad
está amenazadora expresión es fácil de
calcular